was treibt diesen mann an was ist sein
ziel
das sind die fragen die man wladimir
putin stellen muss und ich stelle sie
meinem gast in dieser herzlich begrüße
ruhiger von fritsch sie sind bis 2019
botschafter in moskau gewesen sie haben
vielfach wladimir putin getroffen
wenn sie ganz kurz was schwierig genug
ist sagen wollten was ist das ziel von
drei punkten ich denke das hat sich
verändert wir haben es mit einem anderen
putin zu tun bei dem
ursprünglich verletzungen demütigung
obsessionen zum teil immer stärker in
den vordergrund treten er transportiert
traumata nach außen und nimmt für sich
und sein land das recht als einziges
dieses großen kontinents besonders
beleidigt zu sein und konzentriert nicht
anderen dass sie ebenfalls ihre
schwierigkeiten haben wovon er geleitet
ist ist das wird immer deutlicher
inzwischen ich denke das hat sich
geändert
die tiefe verbitterung über das vergehen
des alten russischen reiches das mit der
sowjetunion zusammengebrochen ist das
letzte kolonialreich affären und der vom
volk ganz offensichtlich die ziele so
weit es geht dieses wiederherzustellen
sie haben ein buch geschrieben über ihre
zeit in moskau und das beginnt mit einem
treffen mit wladimir putin und endet
auch mit einem treffen als sie sich
quasi aus moskau verabschieden sie sind
ihm persönlich begegnet was hat er für
einen eindruck auf sie gemacht wir haben
ja viele porträts von ihm gesehen und
gehört
auch von menschen die sehr viel mit ihm
zu tun hatten sie haben gerade gesagt er
hat sich verändert auch in den jahren in
denen sie in moskau waren ich würde es
mir über die strecke sehen was man immer
wahrgenommen hat das war das unter einer
scheinbar sehr kontrollierten oberfläche
auch im gespräch ich hab mir natürlich
nicht so sehr im unmittelbar gespräch
erlebt dass auch mehr wenn ich deutsche
politikerinnen und politiker begleitet
habe die beim waren war es dass unter
dieser kontrollierten oberfläche eine
höhere aggressivität zu stecken schien
die dann manchmal dem gespräch auch ganz
plötzlich ausbrach und gesprächspartner
verunsicherte auch wir sind ja
überrascht über das was jetzt passiert
ist
ein schreckliches drama deutet sich da
an
deswegen muss man über ihn und seine
motive noch ein bisschen mehr erfahren
wir haben aus seinem leben gelernt dass
er sehr
einfachen verhältnissen groß geworden
ist dass er später ab zwar im grunde
1975 angefangen hat für den geheimdienst
zu arbeiten
geheimdienst offizier gewesen ist wie
stark wird ihnen diese arbeit
beeinflusst haben da geht es um
täuschung um dies informationen in der
spionage ist das etwas was wir heute
wieder finden darauf hat er selber die
antwort mal gegeben hat einmal gesagt
einmal kgb immer kgb und in der tat muss
man feststellen dass sein denken seine
wahrnehmung der wirklichkeit sehr stark
von typisch geheimdienstlichen denken
geprägt ist und vor allem in der
sowjetischen tradition und dazu gehört
die vorstellung dass man von großen
verschwörung umgeben ist die ständig
bemüht sind aus dem ausland kommen
natürlich die verhältnisse im lande zu
ändern einem selber die macht zu wollen
und das führt zu einem blinden fleck in
der analyse muss man sagen weil man
nicht bereit ist wahrzunehmen dass
beispielsweise unmut in der bevölkerung
tatsächlich ursachen hat sondern es muss
immer das böse ausland gewesen sein dass
das anstiftet und dieser verschwörungs
ängste dieser einkreisung ängste prägen
offenkundig bis heute sehr stark und
vielleicht immer stärker seine
wahrnehmung und damit auch sein handeln
wenn wir das als eskalationsstufen
begreifen was passiert ist in den
letzten jahren
ist das eine taktik von anfang an
gewesen oder war sogar eine strategie
die zu dem geführt hat was wir jetzt in
der ukraine erleben
das ist meines erachtens keine strategie
es gibt träume denen man nach hängt und
die man verfolgt und die man
zurückgestellt hat gegenüber der
zustimmung das muss man festhalten
russland zu einer europäischen
friedensordnung die souveränität und
territoriale integrität von staaten vor
uncut daran hat man sich orientiert das
wird im moment über bord geworfen und
das ist das was die situation
gegenwärtig auch so gefährlich macht wir
haben gesehen dass mit dem angriff auf
die ukraine 2014 nämlich der annexion
der krim und jenem krieg den russland im
südosten des landes entfesselt hatte man
sich davon schon ein stück weit
verabschiedet hatte das hat man so
pseudo realistisch versucht irgendwie zu
rechtfertigen mit dieser schlimmen
argumentation streams ja aber eigentlich
irgendwie nicht aber eigentlich gehörte
die green irgendwie immer zu russland
und hat dann sollte volksabstimmung
macht und anderes mehr man hat
inzwischen selbst diese fassade fallen
lassen die maskerade ist weg man hat vor
einer woche noch gesagt wir wollen über
den anschluss dieser republik im wege
des unser friedensprozesses sprechen das
sagt er neben olaf scholz stehen bei der
pressekonferenz und ohne dass sich
irgendetwas ändert tritt er salopp
gesagt dieses abkommen wenige tage
später in die tonne vollzieht nicht nur
die anerkennung sondern geht darüber
hinaus und widerspricht sich selber
indem er die ukraine an greift denn das
hat er definitiv ausgeschlossen und all
das führt uns denke ich zu der einsicht
dass wir es mit dem denken handeln und
entscheiden eines mannes zu tun haben
und ich denke ein schlüsselmoment aus
dem wir das selber ableiten können ist
die sitzung des sicherheitsrates der
einberufen hatte zu anfang der woche
bevor er diesen anschluss verfügt wo ihm
eben nicht 1 zk der kpd es ein politbüro
gegenüber sitzt wo jemand möglicherweise
aufsteht und sagt von dem gewicht eines
gramm ico des früheren außenministers
leonid breschnew gegenüber so geht das
nicht wir müssen das anders machen
hinter verschlossenen türen seine offene
sitzung wo die wichtigsten
entscheidungsträger des landes
eigentlich die claqueure und schulbuben
behandelt werden die werden gemaßregelt
zurechtgewiesen und nur mal ein beispiel
zu nennen einer jener von dem man immer
hätte sagen können das wäre
möglicherweise valabler nachfolger wird
so weit getrieben ist generell stehen
der chef des auslandsgeheimdienstes dass
er beginnt sich zu verhaspeln zu
versprechen zur ordnung gerufen werden
muss das hat die ganze situation
offenbart
ich würde mit ihnen gerne und den
zuschauern und zuschauern natürlich
gerne mal reinschauen in diese berühmte
rede von 2001 eine rede die wir uns
heute ja kaum vorstellen können sie
haben ja von der entwicklung gesprochen
die das offenbar bei ihm selber auch
stattgefunden hat
wir sind natürlich am anfang des aufbaus
der demokratischen gesellschaft und der
markt es gibt auch diese wege die hürden
und hindernisse die es zu überwinden
kamen aber abgesehen von der objektiven
problem und meinem fall aufrichtig ganz
ehrlich gesagt von eigener und
gewandtheit schlägt und dann alle das
starke leben billiger herz russlands
welches für vollwertige zusammenarbeit
und partnerschaft eröffnet ist ich will
dann kaum
von partnerschaft von herzen also auch
von emotionen
europäischen emotionen ist das damals
falsch verstanden worden er spricht am
anfang dass es eigentlich denke ich das
wichtigste an dieser rede vom aufbau von
demokratie und marktwirtschaft und
russland die rede handelt über weite
strecken von russland er hat versprochen
in russland zu schaffen dass er nicht
geschaffen hat woran das gelegen hat
dafür kann man viele gründe angeben ein
ganz wichtiges ist denke ich dass es ein
so autokratisch verfasstes system wie es
damals ja bereits im ansatz ist
fast unmöglich macht dieses zu
transformieren tatsächlich in einem
demokratisch mit bestimmtes system das
überdies die bedingungen eines
autokratischen system sun dazu verleiten
eben nicht eine echte marktwirtschaft
zuzulassen sondern im prinzip wieder
eine staatswirtschaft die sind heute bei
ich glaube 70 prozent staatsanteil an
der russischen wirtschaft das heißt er
selber scheitert oder verweigert die
schaffung dieses demokratischen
marktwirtschaftlichen westlich
ausgerichteten russlands und in dem
masse wird daran scheitert und sein
system verhärtet im innern repressiv und
zunehmend deswegen eben auch klassische
autoritär nach außen zunehmend aggressiv
macht er natürlich diese partnerschaft
auch unmöglich und was die partnerschaft
in der substanz angeht denke ich müssen
wir darauf blicken wie es der westen
eigentlich damals damit um wenn wir auf
dieses jahr gucken da sind wir bereits
in wichtigen elementen der
zusammenarbeit 2001 hatte die rede hält
wir haben gemeinsam die große ordnung
europas verabredet in der charta von
paris budapest am amur an damit vielen
anderen vereinbarungen mehr wir haben
als zum ersten mal als nato mit einem
anderen staat ein abkommen geschlossen
die nato russland grund akte die im
wesentlichen darauf zielt die anstehende
erweiterung der nato abzufedern russland
stimmt den dadurch tun wir verabreden wo
auf welcher seite der grenze wie viele
truppen stehen dürfen daran hat die nato
sich bis heute durch der fall trotz der
verletzung durch russland von 2014
gehalten diese hat er heute endgültig
zunichte gemacht und wir haben uns
darüber hinaus und das ist denke ich
wichtig zu sehen immer wieder bemüht
russlands besondere situation russland
besondere interessen russlands besondere
größe in rechnung zu stellen durch
vereinbarung die wir angeboten haben und
deutschland denke ich hat dabei eine
wichtige und gute rolle gespielt auf
unser drängen ist die g7 zur g8
erweitert worden hat europa räume der
zusammenarbeit angeboten haben der
ungeheure bilaterale anstrengungen
unternommen werden die andere seite
weitgehend auf ihren händen gesessen
hatte gesagt lasst euch was neues
einfallen tut das hier sinn unserer
verletzung geht damit um und nicht sieht
wie alle ihrer verletzungen haben zum
teil ich russland verfügt aber diese
pariser charta also diese vereinbarung
wie ist eigentlich das gleichgewicht
jetzt in europa nachdem der ost west
konflikt beendet ist da wird immer
wieder gerade von russischer seite
gesagt da habt ihr unsere sensibilitäten
nicht berücksichtigt es wird heute immer
wieder gesagt ihr habt nicht verstanden
was russland eigentlich wollte wir sind
ein europäisches land wir wollten
eigentlich eine enge partnerschaft mit
euch haben ist dieser vorwurf berechtigt
noch einmal wir haben uns intensiv mit
den genannten beispielen darum bemüht
diese partnerschaft als gesonderte
partnerschaft aufzubauen eine
zusammenarbeit mit der europäischen
union angeboten vieles unternommen und
wenn russland heute sagt ihr habt uns
damals über den tisch gezogen ist das
finde ich eine beleidigung fast der
qualitäten der russischen diplomatie ich
schätze trotz unterschiedlicher
auffassung einer russischen kollegen
hoch wegen ihrer qualifikation und sie
sind gute unterhändler und sie haben
damals diese carter und andere mit
ausgehandelt unterschrieben genauso wie
der vorläufer bizarres denn wladimir
putin selber erhoben hat michael
gorbatschow habe vergessen zu verabreden
dass die natürlich erweitert werden soll
das ist ja absurd wenn man sieht wie gut
russland dabei ist zu verhandeln und wie
gut russland ist seine interessen
durchzusetzen nein es ist das damals
verabredet worden und verhandelt worden
dass alle seiten gut und richtig wurden
und von dieser ordnung verabschiedet
sich russland gorbatschow hat das ja
mehrfach in interviews auch bestritten
dass es da keine vereinbarung gegeben
hat wenn wir aber auf die karte gucken
und das ist genau der vorwurf der immer
wieder jetzt hoch kommt der vorwurf ihr
kesselt uns ein da ist ne nato die nato
ist aggressiv die schickt nämlich unter
anderem auch amerikanische flugzeuge
direkt an die grenze etwa nach polen das
hat sie jetzt noch mal verstärkt wenn
wir diese karte uns angucken dann
scheint sie ja auf den ersten blick zu
dokumentieren dass russland immer weiter
eingekesselt wird auf der anderen seite
ist das doch auch ein
vertragsbestandteil gewesen jedes land
konnte entscheiden wem es sozusagen
näher sein wollte ob der nato europa in
die eu einzutreten
warum plötzlich ist das ein ja schon
fast psychologisches problem für
russland zu sagen wir fühlen uns
eingekesselt wir fühlen uns bedrängt ich
habe michael gorbatschow den ich oft
getroffen habe selber dazu gefragt und
er das gesagt was er auch in interviews
gesagt hat es ist ein mythos dass es
damals solche verbrennung gegeben hat
und ich will mal zwei historische
konstruktionen anfügen um das zu
illustrieren warum das ein mythos ist
oder sein muss erstens man stelle sich
vor
1990 den zwei plus vier verhandlungen
als das angeblich verabredet worden ist
hätte die westliche seite
dem generalsekretär des zk der kpd su
michail gorbatschow gesagt übrigens wir
werden lettland nicht in die nato
aufnehmen ein land das bestandteil der
sowjetunion ist und die sowjetunion
bestandteil eines existierenden bündnis
und michael gorbatschow hat im gespräch
und interviews hinzugefügt das ist doch
unvorstellbar dass wir in einer
situation wo der warschauer vertrag noch
existiert darüber reden ob der mitglied
austreten würden und zweites
historisches beispiel man stelle sich
mal vor helmut kohl bundeskanzler reist
1992 und das unabhängig gewordene
lettland und sagt in riga also liebe
freunde schön dass er jetzt frei seite
und unabhängig ihr habt ein
schreckliches schicksal auch durch uns
erfahren aber auch durch die sowjetische
annexion aber wie es weitergeht das
müsst ihr mit euch alleine ausmachen
6500 soldaten die einer million auf der
russischen seite gegenüber stehen ich
selber bin als junger diplomat in polen
auf posten gewesen und habe natürlich
die frage gestellt in den 80er jahren
sozialistisches polen welchen weg könnte
würdet ihr denn wählen wenn ihr frei
wert zu werden aber erst gesagt du bist
ja naiv das wird nie passieren die
möglichkeit bekommen wir nicht aber
zweitens wie kannst du dir denn
vorstellen dass wir nicht den weg in die
parlamentarische demokratie in die
wirtschaftliche ordnung des westens und
in den schutz der westlichen bündnisses
vollziehen würden und damit sind wir bei
den punkt einkesselung einkreisung und
so weiter es ist ein schutz den diese
länder sich selber gesucht haben die
nato ist ein verteidigungsbündnis die
nato bedroht niemand wohingegen das
heutige russland mit militär und heute
noch schlimmer als in der vergangenheit
in drei europäischen staaten steht in
georgien in der ukraine und in der
republik moldau es ist russland das im
europäischen raum aggressiv aus
gegriffen hat und das erste
verteidigungsbündnis das übrigens sehr
interessant oder militärbündnis dass in
russland in europa sich ausgeweitet hat
war der vertrag über kollektive
sicherheit denn russland dominiert der
zuletzt in kasachstan eingegriffen hat
und da tritt belarus ein das heißt das
erste land das hat 1 992 dass einem
solchen militärbündnis beitritt ist
eines das heute den von russland
dominierten bündnis zu noch mal auf die
karte zurück vielleicht können wir die
gerade auch noch mal zeigen
die länder die jetzt sehr nah an den
grenzen zu russland sind etwa polen sie
haben gerade beschrieben wie die
reaktion auf ihre frage und polen war
als sie dort waren welche sorge müssen
die haben gerade auch die baltischen
staaten bereits mit der annexion der
krim und im krieg den russland im
südosten der ukraine seinerzeit also
2014 entfesselt hat natürlich und das
habe ich als botschafter in moskau der
ich ab 2014 da war hautnah miterlebt im
gespräch mit den kollegen alle urängste
historische nur ängste wach geworden in
diesen ländern nämlich annektiert
gewesen zu sein von russischen reich
oder der sowjetunion geteilt gewesen zu
sein wie polen überfallen gewesen zu
sein wie polen und andere mehr und
russland sieht diese ängste nicht
sondern redet immer nur von seinen
eigenen sicherheitsbedürfnis zum
längsten natürlich sind die wichtig
natürlich müssen in rechnung stellen
aber gerade deswegen haben wir auch
verabredungen getroffen wie die nato
russland grund akte die die erweiterung
der nato absichern sollte und über die
leute mehr putin sehr positiv gesprochen
hatte hat nach 2004 bei der erneuten
erweiterung der nato gesagt jedes land
soll das bündnis wählen in denen es
seine sicherheit am besten aufgehoben
fühlt wladimir putin 2004er von fritsch
die werden in dieser konstellation in
europa auch sensibel darauf reagieren
was etwa im balkan passiert wir reden
immer von den baltischen staaten wir
reden von polen
die der schulterschluss die nähe
zwischen serbien und russland ist sehr
groß die ist auch traditionell sehr groß
es gibt schon sehr starke bemühungen
auch der nationalisten in serbien und
auch in bosnien sie stärker russland
zuzuwenden haben wir da den nächsten
konfliktpunkt nun zum einen muss jedes
land seinen weg selber bestimmen und
wählen niemand zwingt serbien der nato
oder europäischen union beizutreten
dennoch große aufregung in moskau als
montenegro an der adria gelegen der nato
beitrat mit ich weiß es nicht 1000
soldaten 2000 soldaten oder so was
dahinter offenbart sich dieses alte
großmacht denken dass insgesamt im
russischen handeln gegenwärtig wider
offensichtlich wird das denken in
kategorien des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
mit großen mächten die dinge unter sich
verabreden die kleinen sitzen nicht mit
am tisch aber werden anschließend
angewiesen wo sie rechts und links auf
dem sofa zu sitzen haben großmächten die
sich einflusszonen
einflusssphären pufferzonen definieren
und sozusagen gegeneinander ausrichten
das ist eine ordnung die in zwei
weltkriegen schrecklich gescheitert ist
deswegen haben wir nach ende des zweiten
weltkrieges jene ordnung richtigerweise
verabredet die den frieden in europa bis
heute gewertet hat nämlich die
multilaterale orden und
gleichberechtigter staaten wo jeder
souveränität entscheiden kann welchen
weg er gehen will das haus europa ist
ein sehr wichtiger und sehr prägnanter
begriff den wladimir putin auch
verwendet hat bei seiner rede auch da
noch mal ganz kurzer ausschnitt
wir schlagen heute eine neue seite in
der geschichte unserer bilateralen
beziehungen auf und wir leisten damit
unseren gesamten gemeinsamen beitrag zum
aufbau des europäischen hauses
dieses europäische haus ist nicht
zustande gekommen was war der
entscheidende grund dafür dass das nicht
funktioniert hat ganz wesentlich ist die
autokratische entwicklung russlands den
weg den es entschieden habt eure seine
führung entschieden hat zu nehmen diese
großmacht die tüten dieses aufgreifen
wollen dass wir jetzt auch wieder
erleben ganz grundsätzlich aber gilt
europa russland dem ich natürlich
unterstreichen in tiefer sympathie
verbunden ist und bleibt ein
europäisches land und die idee eines
gemeinsamen raum ist von wladiwostok bis
lissabon oder von mir aus auch bis
vancouver ist nicht falsch und bleibt
richtig und das bleibt ein gutes ziel
nur tut der russische präsident
gegenwärtig alles um das unmöglich zu
machen wir haben versucht darauf
hinzuarbeiten mit den genannten vielen
verabredung vereinbarung mit
unterstützung beispielsweise bei der
transformation der russischen wirtschaft
das ist ja ist der großen dilemma des
heutigen russlands dass seine wirtschaft
so verfasst ist dass sie eigentlich
nicht wirklich zukunftsfähig ist und ich
denke dass steht ein stück weit auch
hinter dem gegenwärtigen ausgreifen die
einsicht dass trotz mancher fortschritte
die man hat bei innovation infrastruktur
ausbauen anderem man eben sehen muss wie
andere davon ziehen der westen europas
die usa aber vor allem aus china und
hiergegen versucht man sich quasi
zu schützen indem man seine position
konsolidiert mitnimmt was gibt alles
arrangiert um sich möglichst stark
alleine aufzustellen und dahinter
verbirgt sich aber auch eine gigantische
herausforderung für russland die
langfristig dem land das leben noch mal
zusätzlich schwer machen könnte
abgesehen von diesen ungeheuren
strukturellen defiziten der wirtschaft
die man nicht in der lage ist obwohl man
immer behauptet man wolle das zu
überwinden also ich meine diese
unendliche abhängigkeit vom export von
öl und gas diese bürokratie die
korruption der unter schleift die
bereicherung einiger weniger an der
spitze und die zunehmenden sorgen der
anderen menschen alles dinge die man
offenbar länder angreifen will was
verbirgt sich dahinter eine potenziell
einsichtige einseitige abhängigkeit von
china langfristig das ist ein verhältnis
das russland versucht zu pflegen man
sagt strategische partnerschaft nach
peking zu dem spiel ist großer freund
und wo steht china es ist die
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft der erde und
die russische volkswirtschaft ist etwas
kleiner als die italiens das ist eine
juniorpartnerschaft die langfristig
vorstand zum problem werden kann und da
wäre ganz grundsätzlich wenn russland
bereit wäre dies zu tun ein
interessanter weg für gemeinsamkeit in
dem wir mit russland zusammenarbeiten
und versuchen solche herausforderung
gemeinsam zu meistern china hat ja schon
erklärt bei den ersten entwicklungen
dass das auf dem internationalen parkett
nicht funktioniert dass man so nicht
miteinander umgehen kann das heißt da
ist die sympathie glaube ich auch schon
massiv gesunken wenn sie mit menschen in
russland gesprochen haben und sie haben
in ihrem buch beschrieben wie viel sie
im land gereist sind sie saßen also
nicht nur als botschafter in moskau
sondern sie sind sehr viel durchs land
gereist was haben sie für eine
bevölkerung kennen gelernt von der wir
immer uns fragen warum macht die das
alles mit was bleibt ja übrig muss man
fragen nicht in einer autokratie die
immer repressiver wird und wo es die
alten reflexe des sowjet menschen gibt
es gibt ja sehr interessante
untersuchungen wie dieser service
menschen fester soziologischer terminus
fortdauert und neu weiterlebt und zu
dieser
besonderheit gehört dass urängste
vorhanden sind die sagen vorsichtig ich
misstraue zwar dem staat oder besser
angst vor ihm und die signale die der
staat gegen die bevölkerung aus denn
jetzt sind ja auch dieser repressiven
natur das heißt die menschen machen das
mit und mir tut es neben den
schrecklichen leiters der ukraine
angetan wird neben der zerstörung der
europäischen friedensordnung wir leben
vor allem auch leid darum dass dieses
große und wunderbare land mit seinen
menschen so in geiselhaft genommen wird
von dieser führung das sehen die
möglichkeiten einer entwicklung von
menschen die fleißig sind anstrengungen
bereit gut ausgebildet dass denen das
genommen wird wie lange machen die das
denn mit brassens denn da passiert haben
völlig recht dass alle unruhig vereine
eine wichtige fragen das ist die größte
angst fast der russischen führung neben
dieser behaupteten einkreisung
perzeption ist der schwarze schwan wie
man sagt das heißt die unbekannte
entwicklung die sich plötzlich ereignet
weil das volk die nase voll hat
stichwort kasachstan anfang des jahres
wo plötzlich erfolgssong ausbricht
ukraine haben wir erlebt der protest der
menschen als der präsident der dafür
gewählt worden war sie nach europa zu
führen ihn plötzlich diese perspektive
nahm georgien andere länder mehr diese
entwickeln und der plötzliche ausbruch
von unmut im landes das was man fürchtet
und noch einmal der fehler in der
wahrnehmung ist dass man glaubt das kann
eigentlich nur passieren wenn das von
außen gesteuert und befördert wird nicht
wir tun ja alles gute und richtige für
die menschen die könnten sie unzufrieden
sein aber wir müssen realisieren dass
bereits im russland von heute es
jährlich zu hunderten durch weise
tausenden von protestaktionen kommt weil
die menschen in einer konkreten
situation sich durchaus gegen etwas
wären also wenn konkret gesagt die
müllkippe nebenan giftige gase absondert
und da spielen die kinder dann gehen die
mütter auf die straße und dann weiß die
führung jetzt wird s gefährlich und dann
wird irgendein verantwortlicher
verhaftet und geld auf die sache
geworfen und man versucht das
abzustellen da ist man schnell und gut
diese beiden mittel des herrschens
repression und bestechung
funktionierendes stück weit die angst
die man hat und dadurch erklärt sich
diese massive repression die immer
weiter zunimmt wie ich von russischen
freunden höhere im lande die ist aus der
furcht heraus zu erklären dass man
glaubt solche proteste könnten sie zu
einem massenphänomen
ausweiten und ich muss sagen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob
die bevölkerung in russland bereit ist
das also die führung jetzt macht
beliebig mitzutragen die frage ist wie
weit will sich treiben und wie hoch
werden die kosten lagen die könnten
enorm sein nicht nur alleine solcher
konflikt sehr viel kostet sondern auch
weil die reaktion des westens massiv auf
die einnahmequellen der führung zielen
werden und damit an ihre möglichkeiten
diese bevölkerung dauerhaft zu bestechen
welche rolle spielen die medien sie
haben natürlich in moskau als
botschafter medien in russland sehr
genau verfolgt die medien sprechen im
augenblick nur von einer sache nämlich
von einer verteidigung russlands als ich
in russland war weil die situation noch
ein wenig besser es gab noch etwas mehr
an freien medien das hat man immer
weiter ausgeschaltet das hat man immer
weiter ausgegrenzt journalisten werden
verfolgt kriminalisiert und es gibt fast
nur noch diese staatspropaganda die
genau das sagt was sie sagen russland
muss sich verteidigen russland ist
bedroht mit bizarren behauptung wie die
ukraine werde russland angreifen und
stelle sich das mal vor die ukraine die
auf ihre nuklearwaffen verzichtet hat im
gegenzug für das versprechen russland
seine sicherheit seine grenzen zu
garantieren wolle beschließen die
nuklearmacht russland an so anzugreifen
völlig bizarr aber nachdem putin ihn
sogar noch einen schritt weiter sagt ja
wir sind ja eigentlich von den
atomwaffen bedroht in der ukraine
behauptet da gebe es ja noch welche das
ist eine völlig absurde behauptung
russland selber hat ja diese
vereinbarung getroffen dass es die
abgebaut wurden und noch einmal stelle
sich vor das land ukraine mit seinen
verteidigungs und militär möglichkeiten
wolle diese supermarkt russland
angreifen da zeigt sich ja dieses
defizit in der wahrnehmung muss sich
fragen worauf basiert denn die
einschätzung der russischen führung ist
nicht nur das was sie der bevölkerung
erzählt propaganda sondern ist auch das
was die entscheidung beeinflusst auch
nicht mehr die wirklichkeit die wir
sehen wir mit dem russischen präsidenten
die letzten tage zugehört haben ist das
was er über die ukraine erzählt hat in
keiner weise im einklang mit der
wirklichkeit in der ukraine er versucht
ja zu behaupten da oben sitzt eine
faschistische führung das hat er jetzt
in seiner führung in seiner ansprache
noch einmal gesagt und wir werden die
ukraine and militarisieren und faschist
ii sieren ja
mit einem präsidenten der sich zu seinen
jüdischen wurzeln bekennt oder die
mercedes g auch das stellt man sich
schon mal vor die müssen wir quasi nur
beseitigen und dann werde das
brüderliche ukraine volk ukrainische
volk gerne wieder in russland leben die
realität in der ukraine ist eine völlig
andere das ist ein land das ich in den
westen entwickelt eine junge generation
denkt anders und wenn man eines auf
keinen fall will und fürchte dann ist es
von russland vereinnahmen zu werden wie
gefährlich ist die lage für diejenigen
wir haben eben gesprochen die bei den
baltischen staaten ohnehin sehr sensibel
russland gegenüberstehen wie gefährlich
ist sie für zum beispiel auch polen
wie schätzen sie sein ziel ein was will
er am ende erreichen wo es im
zweifelsfall ein stoppschild die
situation ist deswegen auch so
bedenklich und gefährlich weil der
russische präsident auch schritte
unternommen hat die im widerspruch zu
seinen selbst erklärten zielen
eigentlich sind er hat ja gezeigt dass
diese große drohkulisse der gegen die
ukraine seit ende vergangenen jahres
aufbaute eigentlich nur so ein vehikel
war um sehr viel weitergehende forderung
im grunde ultimaten an den westen zu
richten der westen solle sich
militärisch selber schwächen und auf
erweiterung verzichten und die usa
sollten den nuklearen schutzschirm
herzstück unserer sicherheit fanden von
uns abziehen das waren die ziele die
eigentlich erklärt hat und mit der
militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine zerstört er eigentlich die
erreichbarkeit dieser ziel ist ja
weitergehen weitergehende ziele denn in
dieser situation werden schweden und
finnland sich in der tasche nicht noch
mal überlegen ob sie nicht vielleicht
eine nato beitritts debatte beginnen und
man wird nicht ein wie von ihm
geforderten abzug von nato infrastruktur
von der
ostflanke der nato erleben sondern eher
eine verstärkung auf die wir bisher
verzichtet hatten weil wir mit russland
verabredet haben was passiert und was
nicht passiert aber diese vereinbarung
hat russland
zerstört und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir die großen sorgen die in diesen
ländern existieren und die historisch
begründet sind wahrnehmen ernst nehmen
und ihn zur seite stehen uns bleibt nur
zu hoffen dass vielleicht noch
hinzuzufügen dass der russische
präsident am ende sehr genau weiß was im
artikel 5 des nato vertrags steht
nämlich die gegenseitige
beistandsverpflichtung und der
mitgliedstaaten wir haben am anfang
darüber gesprochen was ich bei wladimir
putin offenbar verändert hat in seinen
jahren an der spitze
am ende ihres buches zitieren sie ein
zitat von wladimir putin was wir heute
wenige jahre danach völlig
unverständlich finden angesichts der
entwicklung er hat ihnen gesagt ich
zitiere helmut kohl in 20 30 jahren dass
in china und indien die starken mächte
die usa gehen ihren eigenen weg europa
und russland das sind die die zusammen
in europa arbeiten genau davon entfernt
er sich wie kommt das ja es wäre das
gute und richtige ziel und ich denke es
ist das ziel das auch wir immer im blick
gehabt haben dass wir diplomatie
politisch versucht haben zu erreichen
und anzustreben es zeigt sich aber dass
dieses russland mit seinen ford
geschleppten traumata und traumata hat
jeder in europa eine schreckliche
geschichte hat jeder und das russische
reich ist nicht das einzige
kolonialreichs zerbrochen ist darüber
können großbritannien und frankreich und
belgien und portugal und spanien und wer
auch immer auch klagen diese belastung
nicht
verarbeitet hat ich halte die nicht
aufarbeitung der geschichte für eine der
größten belastungen und dieser uns jetzt
auf den tisch legt und verlangt dass wir
damit umgehen das hat dem im wege
gestanden und diese autokratische
verfasstheit die eine neigung hat zu
aggressiven handeln das macht diesen weg
immer weiter unmöglich
von fritz ganz herzlichen dank dass ihr
mann waren dankbar an diese sprechgesang
[Musik]